what's up guys it's Friday I'm Jess and
I always look uncomfortable on a couch
probably cuz you're half adamantium I'm
Dan and this is the top 5 news stories
that have happened this week yes that we
got so there's obviously been a lot of
talk over whether the switch is going to
surpass everything that happened with
the WiiU obviously that was kind of a
disappointment for Nintendo but it
sounds like it's going pretty well it
was the best-selling console in July it
beat the Xbox one and the ps4 yeah very
well done to Nintendo the NPD group
reported that the switch is the highest
selling console for July and that's
impart due to the release of splatoon 2
which was the best-selling game in July
everyone's picking that one up speaking
of splatoon 2 there's also a limited
edition bundle coming to North America
in September and you're gonna get a
Nintendo switch a digital version of
splatoon too in a carrying case but
that's not all you go to my special
edition enjoy cons with that it's the
Korean pink very very very pretty split
so you enjoy console I just bought a
switch annoyingly and now I sure I knew
I should have waited I knew I shouldn't
just wait it like another week just
another way I could have gotten those
sweet controllers bit but instead you
told the lady in the store just give me
whatever color I don't care and she was
like what are you sure you have their
preference what color your switches and
Dan said no and now you've got like a
blue and red there's not been any word
yet on whether you'll be able to pick up
those joy Khan's separately hopefully
you can for Dan sake but yeah stay tuned
and we'll let you know when we do I
don't when I first got pokemon blue when
I was like 6 or 7 there was rumors
running around our playground at school
that you could get me too mm-hmm from
the internet existed because now I can
just pull out my smartphone that I show
more servants have I don't actually I
don't know what the youth are doing
these days and you can play pokemon go
and the next legendary coming it's me -
it is me sure is gonna be harder to get
than the other legendary is that I did
expect it's only arriving in exclusive
raid battles which is the same as a
normal rate battle except you need a
special invite to be able to compete in
them ok what do I need to do to get one
so to get the invite you need to have
like completed a raid battle at the same
location as the exclusive raid battle
like recently ok
and so for those worried like how am I
gonna know apparently the Niantic have
said you will have noticed you will be
able to like form a team beforehand and
know what's going on and make sure you
have that invite and you have the
necessary training numbers to be able to
catch that Mewtwo you know them use the
full legendaries to out right now are
now available for the rest of the month
so if you didn't catch them they're
returning to race Niantic also tastes
that there will be other powerful
Pokemon that are going to hatch from
rare eggs that you can get from red
battles so keep an eye on your eggs and
keep walking to hatch them that's how
the game works thanks Jess no worries
for some strange reason I find the only
way I can relax these days is sitting
down and playing the most nerve
shattering game playing on those
battlegrounds yes it's becoming a
problem for me well you're definitely
not the only one because it sounds like
everyone who's playing this game so
recently beat csgo for concurrent users
it's turn 20,000 but it was still behind
dota 2 which is the king it's a lagging
a long way but identity but it has sold
apparently over seven million copies
since launch that's its launch in March
that's according to steams by data so it
is a report these aren't official
figures but that is a huge number and if
true means they've made over 200 million
dollars in revenue my word and that's
even before it's coming out on console
that's coming out first on Xbox one X
this year and it will hopefully becoming
a ps4 later though although that hasn't
been confirmed and they recently added
our controller support to the PC version
so you can give that a batch with an
Xbox controller maybe see how it's gonna
feel on console when it does eventually
launch later this year get off your
phone it's only two and a half weeks
until the launch of destiny - well I'm
reading about the story so it's kind of
relevant well the thing is if you
preorder you can preload on Xbox one
starting next week oh my god i
pre-ordered on ps4 well then you can
preload on August 31st you're gonna wait
a little bit longer but it's not too bad
Bungie also confirmed the destiny - is
gonna have a day 1 update we're not sure
what's in it or exactly how big it's
gonna be but we should be getting more
details closer to the release of the
game
Anala destiny 2 news Bungie has
they're gonna be updating the destiny
companion app on August 22nd it is worth
noting for those of you who do use the
companion app for destiny one it's going
to overwrite any ability for you to use
it in destiny one so you're gonna have
to grab a third party app if you want to
keep managing stuff like your guns and
stuff like that but it's adding new
things
adding plan management for destiny too
so you can join start and manage your
plans and chat to your clan members and
talk about all kinds of cool stuff and
they're also adding an event staff which
is news gonna give you stuff of what's
happening in the world of destiny too
and also stuff like a community events
for anyone who doesn't know what the app
does it's really really handy to have
because you can manage stuff like your
guns on the fly that means you don't
have to go back to the tower in order to
swap out your guns from your bolt and
all that kind of stuff it just makes it
a lot easier for you to be able to get
like a certain gun for a certain
situation so if you've never played
destiny before and destiny toys can be
your first for right the bungees online
shooter definitely grab the companion
app and give it a bash because it's it's
I think it's quite a while one thing
that is different though is unlike
destiny one apparently they're putting
the story in destiny 2 this time and not
housing it early on the app oh I'm sorry
I'm sorry one I picked up a switch early
last week so I've been playing a bunch
of Zelda but Jax has been playing a heap
of Hell blight and I'm actually super
jealous because it looks great look it
is great but I am playing on PC and boy
have there been a lot of bugs you guys
have probably seen reports online that
there was some progression issue bugs
meaning the game would just break and
you couldn't play it anymore as you'd
actually run into one of these in my
play session it's when you're in an area
of the Fenrir cave and you need to carry
a torch so you don't get attacked by a
shadow demon and if you die at a certain
point the checkpoint is behind you in
the dark
so you're just stuck when you respawn
without a torch and there's no way out I
actually had to check a video
walkthrough online find out the geometry
of the cave and try and walk my way
through pitch-black without dying to get
to the next checkpoint it took me about
30 deaths so I think we can confirm the
death isn't a thing but anyway what
happened is the game has now been
patched on ps4 and PC and if you were
waiting for the game to get fixed before
you started playing and
was the time to do that it's changed a
whole bunch of things it's addressed
those game-breaking progression bugs
that I found and that some other people
have found it's also done things like
there are a lot of PC fixes I think it
was a little less broken on ps4 than it
was on Pacey did you was telling me this
morning there was a massive you you were
having yes so apparently at the start
you're on a boat and the credits are
rolling while you run through this
cutscene and I thought it was just a
cutscene but it turns out much like the
start of Skyrim you're supposed to be
able to look around but there's a bug on
PC where you can't look around so I
would just like have to hurt that ass
more everything going by because I
couldn't move the screen there was
another issue where every time I boot up
the game again the run toggle which I
have on because I can't hold down eight
buttons at once is always off by default
your key bindings don't save and your
run toggle doesn't save so fortunately I
hadn't changed any other key bindings
but those who had may have run into an
issue where every time you boot up the
game again your key bindings have all
reset so they fix that they fixed a
whole bunch of things there's also a lot
of combat tweaks that that will affect
those of you playing on ps4 there's a
bunch of balancing things that have
changed for the auto difficulty the
health of cinema you should now be
different in comparison to enemies
there's a whole slew of patch notes that
you can check out in detail if you want
to but basically the game is fixed and
better and even better than it was
before so yeah if you were holding out
now it's a really good time to try it
out that is everything we've got for you
this week thanks so much for joining us
as always do let us know what you
thought of today's stories and have
yourselves a great weekend I have
nothing to add they've learned oh it
really does seem like they're learning
from the lessons that they learned it
really does seem like they're learning
from destiny one good luck okay